we interrupt this program to bring you
[Applause]
[Music]
he was found by Muriel whales in the
middle of nowhere with her husband
Eustace Bagge ah but creepy stuff
happens in nowhere stupid dog
you made me look bad
[Music]
welcome back to Friday's with bareback
I mean that intro was freaking epic I
always think when I got a new one like
whoa this is really good no one's gonna
top this a little bit but it's really
good made by Patti crawl and it's also
making my another in Museum in sugars
and I know a lot of you bros have been
like we don't want a new honey changer
like the old ones he's gonna make an
animated one so go and guard his
Chandler and tell him to hurry up
already
wait am I don't even know what I hope
you bros I had a great Easter I did it
was fun I was saved by the seaside with
my girlfriend and her parents were here
visiting in Sweden you crazy it's been a
really crazy week I always say that
every week but he always gets crazier so
what can you do pretty much last we give
you a nod last week but in the last
Friday's so today I was in the in the
magazine in Sweden and then after that
everyone has been trying to cut like me
and I was in the news in case you
haven't no I'd say in it I'll leave a
link in the description with the
subtitles and whatnot
I never in a million years thought that
this YouTube thing would be like only as
big as it is and as much attention as is
beginning immediately but the I was fun
it was kind of wish we are the recording
in front of with people with a huge
camera in the background and stuff like
that but yeah definitely fun so after
that it's been like a bunch of like yeah
it feels like every freaking magazine
out there is trying to contact me and
want to share my youtube story so
today's Friday Friday the 13th I should
probably do something like special hari
thing I'll see if I think of something
for your breath but yeah I hope you bros
realize even though there's salata
colada stuff going on I'm still trying
to be down a turf and I'm still always
gonna stay close to heroes cuz i if it
wasn't before you bros none of this
would have happened so I'm Nam name
everyone is like don't forget about
Dutch broke Beauty I'm gonna I'm never
forget don't be ridiculous
come here give me a bless to a bro hug
instead in this F I know what let's do
brother
let's do it bro right hug it hug it if
it wasn't awkward enough to brofist
against green life hug the screen is
that anyway okay whatever let's do bro
alright you ready bro you gotta do it
you gotta do it if you just sit there
and don't do it you just think you're
too cool to do it and
- totally well you are a believer
doesn't matter all right here we go you
ready one two three
bro share mode activate